well there's a reason we're talking
about it because the government would
rather give the appearance of doing
something about small boats than
actually solve what are endemic problems
in our immigration system around the
processing of claims around the
deportation of people whose claims are
unsuccessful and crucially the criminal
gangs it's no use government ministers
coming on your program and saying aren't
these criminal gangs absolutely terrible
exploiting people and then voting
against measures in Parliament as
proposed by labor as we did this week
voting against those measures that would
take money but it's a better use in the
National Crime agency to smash the
criminal gangs many of whom are
operating within our own country and
dreadfully exploiting people speeding up
claims deporting people where those
claims were unsuccessful smashing the
criminal gangs that's the way to tackle
the problem that we have with our
immigration system the government aren't
doing any of that and we're spending
millions of pounds every day housing
people in hotels as the price of
conservative failures something about it
of course but in the meantime
um our baji is a good idea
uh well minimum standards have to be met
in terms of housing well I think the
crucial thing here is it won't be
instead of Hotel accommodation I think
this is what the government's trying to
spin is that we've got this problem of
housing people in hotels it can be
expensive we'll put them on barges
instead we put them in Barracks instead
but we have the Absurd uh spectacle of
conservative MPS campaigning against
putting people in barracks in their
constituencies just as they did in
hotels and their constituencies no doubt
it will be the same with barges off the
coast of their constituencies the
fundamental problem we've got to deal
with here is that it takes far too long
to process claims far too long but my
question is is it a good idea in the
meantime I don't think it's going to
solve the problem I don't think it's
going to see people on barges instead of
hotels I don't think is going to bring
the hotel bills down it's going to add
to the cost of a broken immigration
service because they're going to move
them out of hotels and put them into I I
believe it when I see it okay I'll tell
you what's going to happen we've got
hotels that are overflowing with people
there will be barges over flying with
people and until you unless and until
unless and until you speed up the
processing and deal with claims that are
successful and unsuccessful in the right
way and deal with the problem at source
which is Criminal gangs exploiting
people we're going to be back here again
and again and again I thought it was a
bold claim of the Prime Minister say
stop the boats I believe it when I see
it it's not as it's not as headline
grabbing as barges as uh you know the
the measures that are going through
Parliament this week which are
remarkably similar to the measures that
are put forward by pretty Patel
were put forward over the course of the
last 13 years you've got to deal with
the fundamental problem which is the
processing isn't working the decisions
once they're made are not being
implemented in terms of deporting people
whose claims are unsuccessful and we
have got this problem of organized
criminal gangs operating in these
countries six million seven million
pounds a day is outrageous I've got much
better it's an appropriate way of using
the overseas Development Fund I don't
think I don't think it is and also seven
million pounds a day I quite like that
for the NHS actually to bring down
waiting lists I quite like that for kids
in schools who are being I I think
severely disadvantaged by the long-term
impacts of of the of the pandemic on all
of that lost education the impact on
life chances I'd like seven billion
pounds a day to be used to tackle child
poverty which is rising in this country
I've got seven million different uses
for seven million pounds which does not
involve housing people in hotels because
the government have broken our
immigration system it wasn't like this
13 years ago and it's worse now do you
agree with secure starman's decision to
block Jeremy corbyn as a potential labor
MP I do I do and I think Kirsten when he
said he was serious about learning the
lessons from defeat of the last election
when he said he was serious about
ripping anti-Semitism out by its roots
in the party when he when he when he
said he was going to make the labor
party a credible alternative government
not just a protest party he meant it and
I'm afraid Jeremy corbyn's got no one to
blame for this outcome but himself okay
but once the Curious drama spent several
years in Corbin Shadow cabinet saying
that he was going to be the best leader
of this country
why should we trust him now when he said
that then well I think you can judge
here by his actions when he became
leader of the labor party he said that
tackling anti-Semitism within our party
would be his absolute priority he would
get to work on it I think he's done he
think he's gone further and faster than
I would have expected and I think he's
under prime minister and now he's saying
he can't be even an MP well there were
lots of people in the shadow cabinet
under Jeremy corbyn who I had zero
confidence in when it came to tackling
anti-Semitism who denied there was a
problem was never one of them and
whenever I you know kirstan was one of a
very small number of people in the
shadow cabinet under Jeremy corbyn that
I could approach about anti-Semitism who
I thought took it seriously and did what
he could at the time he's now the leader
of the labor party and there's no doubt
that kirst armor has changed the labor
party shown real leadership when it
comes I'm going to come in here Shadow
Secretary of State come on
um he was very happy to serve under this
man to be not only the leader of the
labor party but also the next prime
minister he wanted to be now he isn't is
flip-flopped again I don't think you can
accuse kirstalma of flip-flopping on
Jeremy corbyn and anti-Semitism I think
he has shown real leadership this is
unprecedented in modern British politics
but so was a major political party being
found guilty of breaking the law when it
came to tackling racism within our ranks
kirstama took it so incredibly seriously
when Jeremy corbyn failed to apologize
failed to take responsibility he lost
the whip he wanted him he lost the
chance to be a labor candidate the next
general election that's real leadership
wanted him to be prime minister I think
here starma has shown real leadership
when it comes he's changed his mind he's
flip-flopped together and there's a
sharp contrast between Kia stamina and
Jeremy corbyn that's why people look at
kirstarma and see not just the leader of
the opposition but an alternative prime
minister for our country someone who can
deliver real change he's changed the
labor party he's now in a great position
to be able to change the country that's
what the labor party is about we're not
a protest party we want to affect real
change and compare 13 years of Labor
government and what we achieved to 13
years of conservative government and
change can't come soon so he was wrong
to support him as prime minister well I
think the labor party got itself into a
terrible mess under Jeremy corbyn worse
defeat since 1935 and had kierstama been
the leader of the late party in 2017 or
2019 we wouldn't have gone down here
wrong to support Jeremy corbyn as prime
minister well kirst armor I think like
the rest of the labor party tried to
make the best of a bad situation so he
was wrong
we made look we made when Jeremy corbyn
was leader of the labor party and we
could see that things were not going the
way that they should people made
different choices to try and bring about
uh I think the the best possible he was
happy to serve in his shadow cabinet I'm
glad Kia stalmer was in Jeremy corbyn's
Shadow cabinet because as you know when
he was in that shallow cabinet he was
one of the few people that I could go to
on anti-Semitism and knew that they
would take it seriously he tried to
influence from within I made a different
choice but I don't think thinking about
the different choices that were made
under Jeremy corbyn's leadership I don't
think that my choice was any more
virtuous than kirstalmers actually we
tried to make the best of a bad
situation thankfully those days are gone
the labor party has changed under
kyostarma's leadership he is a credible
alternative prime minister for this
country he would affect real change
whether it's rescuing the NHS from its
worst crisis in history tackling child
poverty and deep inequality in our
country make Britain Stand Tall on the
world we're out of time you'll have to
get off that soapbox and we'll just
again soon